Es gibt besteht wenig über das physikerinnen, und physiker
So heißt debattieren wir über die stringtheorie denn da fängt es schon an handelt es sich überhaupt
um eine theorie wenn man, sie weder beweisen
Noch, widerlegen kann dennoch ist auch klar die stringtheorie schafft es nicht nur die struktur der materie in ihren
kleinsten bausteine sondern zeitgleich auch das
Universum im großen und ganzen zu erklären quasi eine. Theorie von allem eine super spannende sache also, und so habt
Ihr euch das als thema für dieses video gewünscht auf whatsapp alle wichtigen facts thing theorie bekommt
ihr also jetzt herzlich willkommen zu sein sind action
Erstens die stringtheorie kurz und knapp erklärt mit unseren vorstellungen von einem dreidimensionalen
Raum in dem wir uns in unserem alltag bewegen kommt man bezüglich der stringtheorie nicht sehr weit denn hier gibt es einfach gesagt viel
Mehr als links und rechts und hoch und runter und vorwärts rückwärts
Stringtheorie täter. Gehen. Davon aus dass es sehr viel mehr dimensionen gibt. Ein weiterer punkt der stringtheorie es wird
Davon, ausgegangen dass materie nicht aus atomen oder noch kleineren teilchen besteht sondern eben aus strings die sich in einer 10
Dimensionalen raumzeit bewegen vorzustellen wie fäden oder linien die wie die saiten einer gitarre
schwingen und der folgende effekt sprengt unsere vorstellungskraft
noch, einmal mehr denn, einige dimensionen sollen quasi
eingerollt sein also ein bisschen
So wie wenn, man, ein foto des universums zusammenrollt aber der ansatz ist auf jeden fall super spannend nicht materie stößt
Sich hier gegenseitig ab sondern schwingungen also dass hier das sind quasi schwingungen die irgendwie nicht. Zusammen
kommen die wahl oder licht ja wo wir auch nichts
Zu fassen bekommen verhält sie sich auch mit der materie nur dass sie, anders miteinander reagiert
Eine absolut spannende vorstellung alles sind nur schwingungen strings zweitens wie und warum ist die stringtheorie
Entstanden ja ins leben gerufen wurde in die stringtheorie durch experimente mit protonen. Kollisionen wie beispielsweise
Am lhc dem large hadron collider bei genf denn tatsächlich wirkt es so als seien die einzelnen quarks durch elastische
Fäden miteinander verbunden und so haben teams aus theoretischen physikern
Und physiker sind schon vor einiger zeit versucht die eigenschaften der sogenannten patronen mit dem schwing verhalten
Eindimensionaler seiten. Beziehungsweise vreden zu erklärt konzert 70 kamen. Dann die ersten swing theorien
Heraus aber es sollte noch mindestens 30 jahre dauern, ehe dann. So etwas wie ein durchbruch in sachen strings erzielt werden
Konnte drittens wurde ist die stringtheorie überhaupt zu gebrauchen es ist keineswegs so dass die stringtheorie
In den labor kellern dieser welt verrottet im gegenteil denn sie. Hat eine sache tatsächlich geschafft
Ihr wisst es vielleicht dass man sowohl die. Quantenmechanik als auch die allgemeine relativitätstheorie
als eckpfeiler der
Physik bezeichnen kann beide sind rund 100. Jahre, alt und
Auch wenn sie, sich bestens bewährt haben kann man. Sie nicht wirklich. Zusammen bringen doch die stringtheorie ist die heißeste kandidatin
dafür durch sie können theoretische
Unvereinbarkeiten zwischen der quantenphysik, und der allgemeinen relativitätstheorie von albert einstein
Erstmals aufgelöst werden das besondere an strings ist zudem dass man mit ihnen
Objekte bilden kann die schwarzen löchern ähneln und schwarze löcher wiederum sind großartig
Um die quanten aspekte der gravitation zu erforschen in den 90er. Jahren gab es dann in diesem
Zusammenhang den großen durchbruch es ging, um, hadronen also alle teilchen die quarks enthalten die forschungsteams fanden damals
heraus dass es nicht nur eine einzige
Theorie für diakonische physik gibt stattdessen entdeckten sie neue modelle mit denen, sich die stringtheorie in einer fünf
dimensionalen raumzeit beschreiben lässt und das bedeutet auch wir sind nicht in der lage
Zu unterscheiden ob die reale welt vier oder fünf dimensional ist es kommt stattdessen auf die perspektive an nämlich
Obwohl sie als eine welt aus teilchen oder. Eben aus strings aus fäden betrachten physikalisch gesehen
Hat jedenfalls beide dieser beschreibung ihrer vorzüge der vorteil der stringtheorie sie beschreibt vor allem
Große abstände zwischen den quarks sehr gut das kann die quanten chrome oder namik nicht so verlässlich liefern viertens wie kann man die stringtheorie
visualisieren oder gar messen
ein
forschungsteam vom max planck institut für gravitationsphysik hatte 2016 gemeldet dass sie die versteckten
dimensionen des trinks entdeckt haben, und zwar in gravitationswellen
Die existenz von gravitationswellen hatte bereits albert, einstein vorausgesagt doch, er bezweifelte damals
noch dass man ihre existenz jemals nachweisen könnte möglich wurde, das dann durch die beiden lego detektoren in den usa
Wo steht für laser interferometer
Gravitation wave observatorio doch was hat das mit links
Zu tun das forschungsteam hatte berechnet dass die zusätzlichen. Dimensionen der raumzeit die die string theorie voraussagt
Auswirkungen auf die gravitationswellen struktur haben könnte
und genau dies müsste man nachweisen
Um die stringtheorie zumindest indirekt zu bestätigen die detektoren für gravitationswellen sind dafür allerdings momentan
Nicht empfindlich genug für die bestätigung müssen, wir also noch auf den riesigen
Gravitationswellen gedeckter leiser warten der zwischen sonne und erde gebaut wird und der ja frühestens irgendwann in den
2030er jahren voraussichtlich starten wird fünftens wie sieht die zukunft der stringtheorie aus im gegensatz
Zu anderen rechen techniken steckt die stringtheorie quasi noch in den kinderschuhen ihre entwicklung ist. Mühselig
Und zeit intensiv geforscht wird dazu beispielsweise am deutschen elektronen-synchrotron desy
In hamburg fest steht aber solange es nicht mehr hinweise zur stringtheorie gibt wird. Auch die diskussion. Um sie nicht beendet sein wenn
Ihr also nicht so sting theorie. Und zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollen oder als erstes informiert werden wollt dann endet
Meine telefonnummer hierbei whatsapp. Und in anderen messengern dann erfahrt. Ihr von mir vor allen anderen vom neuesten video täglich garantiert
Einfach hier draufklicken unsere begrüßen habe ich. Ein kleines, goodie. Und natürlich nicht das abo mit der genau glocke vergessen
Und hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken gravitationswellen jetzt geht die forschung richtig los ansonsten bis. Dann
bleibt dran